hola y bienvenidos a este especial de
emigrantes el programa semanal de france
24 sobre el éxodo les saluda valeria
saccone desde pacaraima la última ciudad
de brasil antes de la frontera con
venezuela precisamente para esta
frontera hasta la fecha han cruzado
cerca de 650 mil migrantes venezolanos
bienvenidos a este programa especial
[Música]
en la actualidad unos 4500 venezolanos
viven en uno de los 11 abrigos
habilitados por el gobierno de brasil y
acnur en boavista la capital del estado
de roraima la mayoría espera ser
trasladada a una de las regiones más
ricas del país donde podrán encontrar un
nuevo hogar y un trabajo los que se
quedan se ven obligados a salir todos
los días en busca de un sustento hoy les
contamos la historia de una familia de
refugiados a los que acompañamos en su
jornada todas las mañanas yumari jason
salen de su carpa para desayunar junto a
sus hijas desde hace un año y medio esta
familia vive en uno de los 11 abrigos
habilitados por el gobierno brasileño en
boavista para hacer frente al éxodo de
venezolanos que huyen de la crisis
económica
la operación acogida lanzada en 2018 y
coordinada por el ejército se encarga de
la alimentación de las 550 personas de
este abrigo y de las 4000 que ocupan los
otros campos de refugiados de un mar
decidió mudarse a brasil para dar a luz
a su quinta hija no están cobrando 300
dólares para el parto de ella y era muy
difícil para nosotros conseguir ese
dinero 1510 de llegar aquí de alós y
bueno en ese momento no pensaba en cómo
me iba a ir cuando se recuperó del parto
empezó a la pandemia del coronavirus y
se quedaron atrapados en brasil
el calor es intenso y omar ha plantado
este pequeño jardín para amenizar su
estancia
en venezuela trabajaba como ambulante y
aquí sigue con su profesión vende ropa y
sus hijas le ayudan con las palomitas
mientras jason se prepara para irse al
trabajo
el soldador y hace 7 meses encontró un
empleo en un taller de recuperación de
piezas industriales gana 15 dólares por
día una suma que hace toda la diferencia
en su frágil economía
este empresario le contrató por razones
humanitarias pero hay otro motivo
venezuela tuvo grandes industrias y
vinieron grandes profesionales nosotros
terminamos acogiendo como aledo hasta
ahora jason no quiso salir de roraima en
la esperanza de poderse reunir con sus
padres y su hijo mayor que se quedara en
venezuela pero ya está deseando mudarse
al sur de brasil donde hay más
oportunidades aquí en brasil el futuro
por lo momento lo veo óptimo este
optimismo inquebrantable es el principal
capital de jason y de los 246 mil
refugiados venezolanos que escogieron
brasil para comenzar una nueva vida
unos 46.000 venezolanos ya han
conseguido el estatus de refugiado es el
dato más alto de toda américa latina a
ellos pueden sumarse otros 100.000 que
en estos momentos están a la espera de
una respuesta del gobierno brasileño
además desde 2018 unos 2500 menores
llegaron solos a pacaraima en busca de
una vida mejor una parte de ellos ha
sido acogida en abrigos especiales
administrados por el gobierno local de
roraima junto con unicef france24 visitó
uno de ellos para conocer la historia de
un adolescente no acompañado vean
por la frontera de pájara y más cerrada
desde marzo por el coronavirus ya
cruzaron cientos de menores venezolanos
no acompañados algunos de ellos se
encontraron abrigo en esta casa de
acogida de varias casas hay varios casos
hay algunos que huyen de su familia
salen de su casa para buscar trabajo
porque muchas veces son los mayores de
la casa y se sienten en la obligación de
apoyar a la familia de conseguir comida
para ayudar al padre ya la madre y
ayudado para yang moo-jin rafael es uno
de ellos se marchó a los 15 años tras
discutir con su padrastro durante dos
años deambulo solo por varias ciudades
de la región minera de venezuela hasta
llegar a brasil siempre me porté bien
pero me sentía bien porque hacía lo que
yo quería como que si fuera mayor de
edad y yo donde yo quería y trabaja
bastante para ganar en las cosas el
sueño de rafael es abrir una peluquería
en una ciudad más grande antes tendrá
que regularizar su situación legal llegó
a brasil sin documentos
antes de eso
mientras en uno de los abrigos para
refugiados
unicef y la ong pedí la anp os dan
clases de portugués a niños venezolanos
es la llamada pedagogía de emergencia os
contamos más uno de los contenidos más
importantes es la lengua portuguesa
porque representa una barrera que los
niños se encuentran en la escuela formal
sin embargo trabajamos con todas las
disciplinas finas super pana es el
nombre de este programa y fue escogido
por los niños refugiados en la jerga
venezolana significa más que amigos los
pequeños aprenden divirtiéndose a la
espera de que reabran las escuelas algo
previsto sólo para 2021 según la onu más
de 5 millones de venezolanos dejaron su
país desde 2018 como consecuencia de la
crisis política y económica unos 264 mil
se instalaron en brasil desde que empezó
la crisis del coronavirus el flujo de
inmigrantes ha bajado sensiblemente pero
la crisis migratoria está lejos de estar
solucionada de hecho los expertos
estiman que cuando reabra la frontera
repunte en el número de los refugiados
muchas gracias por acompañar este
programa especial de emigrantes que
hicimos desde el estado de roraima junto
a nuestro camarógrafo carlos chaval para
más información síganos en france 24 in
france 24 punto com